herzlich willkommen unsere gegenwärtige
situation gleicht einem blindflug
nie zuvor hatten wir eine globale
pandemie von diesem ausmaß
wir wissen vieles nicht testen soziale
maßnahmen und medikamente suche nach
impfstoffen und anti körper tews
es braucht pionierarbeit und geduld wenn
man wissen will mit dem und planbaren
umgehen und wie rückschläge wegstecken
dann lohnt sich das gespräch mit einem
der damit erfahrung hat deshalb habe ich
den piloten abenteurer und psychiater
bertrand piccard gefragt ob er zeit für
uns hat und er hatte zeit ich freue mich
sehr
ganz herzlich willkommen der trompeter
herzlichen dank einer einladung das
thema interessiert mich sehr
ja ja sie haben ja erfahrung mit dem
alleine sein mit der isolation sie haben
tagelang alleine aus gehabt im cockpit
von solar impulse
das heißt ihnen macht das alleinsein im
moment keine mühe
nach mehreren tagen und nächten ganz
allein im kopf von sala im pelz weiß ich
natürlich was isolation ist im breitling
orbiter drei waren es gar 20 tage die
ich allerdings mit meinem co piloten
verbracht habe ein solches eingesperrt
sein kann man auf zwei arten lebe
entweder sehnt man sich das ende herbei
und zählt die stunden und tage in
erwartung einer besseren zukunft
was einer schlimmen hochhäuser
gleichkommt weil die zeit zur unendlich
langsam vergeht
oder man konzentriert sich ganz auf den
augenblick
das momentane erleben die man seinen
gedanken lässt sich gewahr dass man
liebt so geht man mit der zeit
und sie verliert jede bedeutung mit dem
ende der isolation ist man dann
überrascht wie schnell die zeit
vergangen ist
egal ob in der kapsel eines
heißluftballons einem solarflugzeug oder
in seiner wohnung währenden ausgangs
beschränkungen wegen des corona virus
das ist sehr ähnlich sich die zukunft
vorzustellen ist viel beschwerlicher als
im augenblick zu leben also im moment
green bleiben die sind ja tatsächlich
auch psychiater und haben zb auch die
methode der hypnose gelernt ist auch
eine methode die sie in kursen weiter
vermittelt haben
die muss ich mir das vorstellen man
stellt sich ja unter hypnose ist etwas
ein bisschen unheimlich es vorher an die
manipulation
was genau tun sie wenn sie sich selber
hypnotisieren kartoffel in demonstration
bei der bühne hypnose handelt es sich in
der tat zu manipulation
das ist aber nicht die ware über lose
zumindest ist es keine therapeutische
hypnose
sie erlaubt den patienten eine umkehr
des knicks in dem ihr innenleben zum
objekt der konzentration wird für
gewöhnlich richten wir unsere
aufmerksamkeit nach außen auf das was
wir sehen hören spüren und riechen unter
hypnose kehrt man diese aufmerksamkeit
nach innen und wird sich seiner selbst
und der eigenen art mit bewusst nun kann
man seinen gefühlen ängsten und sorgen
begeben
nach dem auftauchen aus der hypnose kann
man seine erfahrungen aus der
visualisierung und mittelbar anwenden
wie ich ist dabei der ein innerer ort
der sicherheit und geborgenheit
experience to go for it security gruppe
a portrait flow batterie
man kann in seinem leben alles verlieren
deshalb ist es wichtig in seinem innern
etwas zu verlangen kann dass einem
niemand nimmt in der selbsthypnose
lernen wie er die beziehung zu unserer
inneren kraft zu entdecken und zu nutzen
es habe club no soll die politik ist das
immer für mich klingt das sehr sehr
ähnlich die viele praktiken der
meditation dass man sich nach innen
wendet diesen 60 diesen sicheren ort in
sich selbst findet was ist der
unterschied
dollar benita zion und es bei der
meditation versucht man ruhe in das
denken zu bringen möglichst wenig
aufkommende gedanken zu haben
die hypnose dagegen macht sich die
bildhafte vorstellung die visualisierung
zu nutzen
auch bleibt man im gespräch mit sich
selbst und dem therapeuten das denken
ist also sehr aktion mannschaft sich
gedanklich eine welt in der man sich gut
fühlt
das unterscheidet sich stark von der
meditation
ich habe irgendwo gelesen sie hätten
sich selber die höhenangst so weg
therapiert stimmt wirklich oder zwischen
märchen und souverän
da stimmt hatte als kind wollte ich in
die fußstapfen meines großvaters vaters
und der astronaut und ich getroffen
hatte
dabei litt ich aber unter solcher
höhenangst dass ich nicht einmal auf
bäume klettern konnte ich dann ein
drachenflieger sah drachenflug wohl
einen der ersten in der schweiz wusste
ich das war mein ding
wenn ich das schaffen würde konnte ich
alles erreichen
ich habe das drachen fliegen als
therapie genutzt um mich mit meinem
innern zu verbinden und vertrauen in
meine innere stärke aufzubauen
denn häufig entwickeln menschen
angstgefühle wenn sie nicht gelernt
haben ihr inneres potential zu nutzen
paradoxerweise funktioniert man sehr gut
wenn man gezwungen ist unter druck das
richtige zu tun
mir ging es mit 16 jahren so als ich
1000 2000 oder 3000 meter über dem boden
an meinem kleinen delta segler und
richtig handeln musste in
drucksituationen steigt unsere leistung
kreativität und konzentration sodass man
viel besser funktioniert lustigerweise
wurden plötzlich auch meine leistungen
in der schule viel besser weil ich
gelernt hatte nicht zu konzentrieren und
keine prüfungsangst mehr hatte japans
bürger wollte sammer ich selber liebe
die berge aber ich habe auch ein
bisschen höhenangst ehrlich gesagt ich
habe mühe über einen graf zu wandern
eines links und rechts ganz steil runter
geht könnte ich zu ihnen die therapie
kommen sie können das weg hypnotisieren
ja sie können lernen ihren safe place
und damit ein gefühl der geborgenheit zu
entwickeln während sie in ihrer
vorstellung einen grat entlang
wenn sie dann auf dem berg grat wandern
werden sie sich dank dieser erfahrung
von sicherheit in same place sehr viel
wohler von safenet experience der
security waren ihre bus remo gubser als
prof
man kann sich damit sehr gut auf etwas
vorbereiten ich habe dies meinen kindern
beigebracht
im hinblick auf prüfungen oder
schwierige situationen im leben als eine
meiner töchter sich neulich auf eine
prüfung vorbereiten musste habe ich ihr
eine kleine hypnose sitzung angeboten
sie sagte mir papa das mache ich jetzt
selber ich habe das ja gelernt dafür
brauche ich dich nicht mehr
das ist ein kleiner im startvorteil in
die ihre drei töchter haben mit diesen
tricks den die er hätte sie dabei
bringen können
ich würde gerne mit ihnen mal kurz
zurückblicken was die größten erfolge in
ihrem leben waren auch um vielleicht
dann davon ausgehend zu verstehen wie
sie ihre strategien von den sie erzählt
haben entwickelt haben
sie haben ja sich sozusagen freiwilligen
schieden eben in diese lockdown
situationen in einem cockpit hinein zu
steigen sie haben es schon erwähnt sie
waren zum beispiel mit dem ballon
breitling orbiter unterwegs wir sind ein
bilder hier dazu sie umrundete 1999 als
erster mit dem heißluftballon die welt
zusammen mit einem partner mit brian
jones und dann sehen wir auch das sonnen
betriebene flugzeug solar impulse
2015/2016 gelangen in der spektakuläre
flug um den erdball gemeinsam mit andré
borschberg rühren sie persönlich diese
bilder hat nicht noch wenn sie sie sehen
ja das berührt mich stark
sie müssen sich vor augen halten dass es
15 jahre brauchte ist dieses flugzeug um
die welt flug 15 jahre
technologieforschung team entwicklung
finanzierung und sponsoring
ich musste lernen ein flugzeug zu
fliegen
denn als ich das projekt soll er in
paris startete hatte ich noch keinen
pilotenschein
wenn man das flugzeug so mühelos
dahingleiten sieht vergisst man leicht
welche schwierigkeiten und anstrengungen
damit verbunden war
das heißt was sie berührt ist sozusagen
das sie gesagt haben nicht möchte dass
machen so viel zeit und energie
investiert haben auch so viele risiken
eingegangen sind und zuletzt fliegt das
flugzeug ressentiments otterstedt ja das
ist ein fantastisches gefühl ich bin
nicht stolz darauf mit einem so
ein flugzeug um die welt geflogen zu
sein sondern dieses projekt trotz aller
probleme während 15 jahren aufgebaut
haben
es lief längst nicht alles wie geplant
und es gab viele momente der frustration
und enttäuschung kein großer traum
realisiert sie von selbst das gilt für
alles was man sich im leben wünscht und
erhofft einen traum zu erreichen
erfordert viel arbeit vielleicht haben
wir heute verlernt hart für etwas zu
arbeiten verantwortung zu übernehmen
entscheidungen zu treffen und die
möglichkeit des scheiterns zu
akzeptieren gerade die angst zu
scheitern und deswegen von anderen
ausgelacht zu werden hält viele menschen
davon ab etwas in angriff zu nehmen
glücklicherweise bin ich früh in meinem
leben mehrmals gescheitert
ich habe mich an den spott der anderen
gewöhnt wenn ich die lust auf etwas
packt zu das schlimmste ist nicht das
scheitern sondern es nicht versucht zu
haben um diese diese vorstellung dass
man nicht angst davor haben sollte dass
sich jemand lustig macht über einen und
da gibt es auch eine schöne geschichte
die in ihrem buch ich in ihrem buch
gelesen habe ich habe ein buch
geschrieben die richtige flughöhe und
bekommt das auch vor nämlich dass sie 14
jahre alt waren als sie ein mofa haben
wollten und ihr vater hat gesagt du
darfst deines haben aber nur wenn du
einen helm aufsetzt und das war
furchtbar peinlich dann in dieser zeit
nämlich nur sie und irgendein alter mann
glaube ich nachher einen hellen an
herzen und sie sagen aber im nachhinein
das hat mich schon geleert nichts sich
davor zu fürchten dass die anderen
überall machen könnten
ja das stimmt mit 14 wollte ich
unbedingt ein mofa und dazu zu gehören
niemand außer einem alten mann und mir
trug ein helm und ich wurde ausgelacht
das hat mir die lust aufs dazu zu
gehören anfangs war das schwierig aber
dann sagte ich mir dass ich eigentlich
richtig liege und es keinen grund gibt
mir die himmel oder die kritik zu herzen
zu
die kritik das gab mir eine gewisse
unabhängigkeit im handeln und denken wir
später sehr nützlich wurde sagte pommer
sie haben schon gesagt wir haben drei
zerstörte die mittlerweile erwachsen die
haben sich erzogen waren sie auch noch
einmal streng damit sie lernen
es ist egal wenn man auffällt das ist
egal wenn sich die anderen lustig machen
geht einen weg zu suchen
ich habe ihnen immer beigebracht wird
sich selbst in frage zu stellen
ich habe ihnen beigebracht dass ein kind
auf einem anderen kontinent drei anderen
religionen einer anderen kultur oder zu
einer anderen zeit möglicherweise ganz
andere dinge lernt in der schule
ich habe gewissheiten infrage gestellt
um ihnen zu zeigen dass es nicht richtig
und falsch sondern alles davon abhängen
wie man denkt ich habe ihnen beigebracht
offen für alle geisteshaltung zu sein
das hat sich als sehr nützlich erwiesen
sie haben ihre studien großem erfolg
abgeschlossen
aber ich habe sie nicht zu guten
leistungen gezwungen sondern ihnen lust
darauf gemacht gut zu sein
gehen wir zurück zu den großen
erfahrungen großen abenteuer ihres
lebens sind was sie daraus gelernt haben
in diesem buch die richtige flughöhe
wird sehr deutlich der wind ist das
ausschlaggebende also die flughöhe aber
auch der wind und sie sagen an einer
stelle eine strategie die man wirklich
verinnerlichen muss ist dass man nicht
gegen den wind geht sondern mit dem wind
schlägt erzählen sie darüber mehr und
sie haben nämlich auch etwas mitgebracht
ein an ein objekt einen glücksbringer
von dem sie glauben dass sie das
entscheiden wer im leben erzählen sie
mal im alter von 16 bis 30 jahren habe
ich gelernt mit gegenwinden zu fliegen
mit einem delta segler einem
ultraleichtflugzeug oder einem
gleitschirm muss man oft turbulenzen
ankämpfen
man entscheidet sich für einen
landeplatz und kämpft sich bis dahin
durch egal in welche richtung die winde
drehen
ein freund hat mir dann angeboten als
psychiater mit ihm zusammen im
eines rennens von den usa noch europa
den atlantik in einem heißluftballon zu
überqueren
ich war kein ballon pilot sagte aber aus
abenteuerlust zu obwohl mir eine innere
stimme sagte ist völlig verrückt
geworden der wind treibt dich vor sich
her ohne dass du etwas dagegen tun
kannst es ist nicht einmal klar ob mit
trockenen fußes auf der anderen seite
ankommst einen monat vor dem rennen
weichen china um im rahmen meiner
ausbildung zum psychiater traditionelle
chinesische medizin zu studieren in
einem antiquitätenladen fand ich diese
medaille
der laden hat hunderte davon und ich
habe absolut keine ahnung weshalb ich
nach dieser medaille griff
ich bat den verkäufer mir die
schriftzeichen zu übersetzen
sein englisch war nicht gerade gut aber
den kern der botschaft konnte ich
verstehen wenn der wind in deiner weg
richtung weht bringt er dir großes glück
das war ein wendepunkt in meinem leben
ich begriff dass es auch eine andere art
des fliegens jahr des lebens kann statt
dafür zu kämpfen auch das unmögliche zu
erreichen könnte man ja das leben und
die würde die man nicht kontrollieren
kann nutzen und das ungewisse
akzeptieren in einem heißluftballon muss
man seine flughöhe ändern wenn man in
eine andere richtung fliegen will
die atmosphäre umfasst unterschiedliche
meteorologische schichten in denen die
winde in unterschiedliche richtungen
gehen
genauso ist es auch im leben wer nur auf
eine art denkt wird nur in eine richtung
getrieben
unterschiedliche lebenswege eröffnen
sich nur durch andere denkweise wenn wir
den ballast unserer gewissheiten
lebensanschauungen und gewohnheiten
abwerfen entdecken wir all die
unterschiedlichen flughöhen im leben und
können schließlich die denkweise wählen
die uns in die gewünschte richtung trägt
auch der ungünstigen windverhältnissen
können wir die flughöhe ändern
auch heute beim corona virus angesichts
der pandemie sind wir eingeschränkt sie
zehnte wirtschaft in die knie
ohne dass wir etwas daran ändern können
aber bei einer
ihre flughöhe können wir eine andere
richtung einschlagen und schauen was wir
damit erreichen
es gilt sich die elemente einer krise zu
nutzen zu machen und zu lernen was wir
nach der krise besser machen kann
auf ihrem jura priska war diese medaille
hat meine sicht auf das leben komplett
verändert die gerne noch ein bisschen
konkreter bei der frage bleiben was das
für unser leben heißt also wie ich sie
verstehe es gibt in jedem leben
turbulenzen wir nutzen diese metapher
des andel's jahr dauern also die winter
sind nicht immer günstig es gibt
turbulenzen
erste regel turbulenzen aushalten nicht
bekämpfen sondern die flughöhe ändern
also irgendeine andere schicht suchen wo
die linde besser sind wenn zu ihnen
jemand kommt als psychiater zum beispiel
der sagt ich habe eine riesen ehekrise
meine frau will nicht verlassen
das ist eine turbulenz in einem leben
ich kann er die flughöhe ändern
man verändert seine flughöhe in dem man
sich fragt wie man bis dahin
funktioniert hat in ihrem beispiel
könnte da man sich die frage stellen was
für eine beziehung sie geführt haben und
was er an sich und sein sozius verhalten
ändern muss damit sich die beziehung
verbessert allein der wunsch nach
veränderung wird aber nichts nützen
solange man auf derselben flughöhe in
seinen denkmustern verharrt ist beim
blockiert wenn man aber neue denkweisen
zu lässt sich hinterfragt und überlegt
wie man anders reagieren könnte eröffnen
sich eine reihe neue wege
nun hat man eine wahl ist das kann ich
jetzt extrem gut verstehen was sie sagen
dass man sozusagen auch die beziehung
dann verändern muss das erfordert
natürlich auch risikobereitschaft dass
erfordert dass man das sicherheitsdenken
aufgeht und auch das ist etwas was sie
beschäftigt sie sagen eine andere
wichtige strategie ist nämlich das
sicherheitsdenken
loszulassen ich gibt keine letzte
sicherheit und die müssen aufhören immer
sicher sein zu wollen
man spricht man von unserer zeit aus
einer vollkasko mentalität wir sind auch
nicht versichert wir haben irgendwelche
frühwarnsysteme und so weiter glauben
sie wir sind zu sicherheits verliebt
ich glaube wir suchen die sicherheit im
außen
obwohl der größere gefahr darin besteht
gefangenen unserer hergebrachten
denkweisen zu werden was wir früher
gelernt haben damals nützlich gewesen
sein
die dinge sind aber stets im fluss wir
haben gelernt uns gegen jeden wandel zu
stemmen und die gewohnte sicherheit
wieder erlangen zu wollen
die meisten veränderungen sind aber
unumkehrbar sie ihre version opel vectra
sie nehmen wir an sie haben ihre stelle
verloren natürlich können sie ihre
arbeitgeber verklagen und vielleicht
obsiegen sie vor gericht und kehren
zurück in ihre arbeit
dort sind sie jetzt aber fast die
beziehungen zu den kollegen sind
schwierig geworden obwohl sie eigentlich
gewonnen haben ist erleben soll fällig
geworden
oder sie fragen sich welche andere
arbeit kann ich nun finden vielleicht
erlernen sie eine neue sprache machen
eine andere ausbildung und finden so
eine stelle die möglicherweise besser
ist als die alte
das bedeutet es ballast abzuwerfen und
die flughöhe zu ändern
natürlich gibt es auch situationen in
denen es sich lohnt den kampf
aufzunehmen
in der mehrheit der fälle ist es aber
wie bei wind man kann in einem
heißluftballon nicht gegen den wir
fliegen
ebenso wenig kann man sich gegen das
leben stemmen krankheit und das alter
oder finanzprobleme geschehen ohne dass
man dafür verantwortlich ist
man hat aber die verantwortung darauf so
zu reagieren dass meine situation
möglichst gut übersteht und vielleicht
sogar weiter kommt darüber was man
ändern kann darüber möchte ich nachher
gleich noch sprechen vielleicht zuerst
noch einmal zurück dieses
sicherheitsdenken loslassen heißt auch
mit dem scheitern rechnen und das
scheitern im leben integrieren
sie selber sind auch gescheitert in
ihrem leben immer mal wieder zum
beispiel mit dem ballon mit dem sie
geschrieben sind da waren die ersten
beiden versuche ja nicht von erfolg
gekrönt beim zweiten versuch durften sie
nicht weiter fliegen weil china den
überflug verboten hat beim ersten
versuchen da würde ich gerne mit ihnen
darüber sprechen
da haben sie so viel kerosin verloren
dass sie nach sechs stunden schon eine
notwasserung machen mussten im
mittelmeer
was war das für ein moment also ehrlich
gesagt ich stelle mir das auch einfach
wahnsinnig gefährlich war sie haben
irgendwann gemerkt das geht nicht weiter
und dann sind sie mit dem fallschirm aus
dem korb rausgesprungen oder wie sind
sie da ins mittelmeer dann gekommen und
wer hat sie gerettet
es war eine völlig verrückte situation
vor dem abflug hielt ich eine
pressekonferenz ab in der ich vor etwa
150 journalisten erklärte dass ich als
kleiner schweizer in drei wochen
erfolgreich um die ganze welt fliegen
würde wo unsere konkurrenten die
milliardär richard branson uns die
fossett gescheitert war und am nächsten
tag nach nur sechs stunden flug trieb
ich im mittelmeer
ich war nicht mit dem fallschirm
abgesprungen sondern hatte den ballon
auf dem wasser aufgesetzt
aufgrund eines kerosin lecks im innern
der kapsel hatten wir atemprobleme der
kleinsten hätte alles explodieren lassen
kann in solch einer gefährlichen
situation gilt es einen ruhigen kopf zu
bewahren und das richtige zu tun waffe
und hatten sie wirklich keine panik wenn
sie in panik geraten sind wir verloren
umso wichtiger ist die vorbereitung über
die hypnose vor dem abheben
visualisieren sie alle möglichen
gefahrensituationen und stellen sich vor
wie sie sie ruhig lösen eine panik würde
ihren sicheren tod betreut sie überleben
nur wenn sie ruhig bleiben ich habe als
auf dem meer aufgesetzte mal runter
gegangen während die kapsel auf dem meer
trieb
zurück an land gab es da natürlich eine
pressekonferenz
was heißt das sie sind nachher
zurückgegangen er hat sie da rausgeholt
wir wurden von einem boot der
französischen küstenwache herausgeholt
an land musste ich dann das schlimmste
schalter meines lebens erklärte ich bin
buchstäblich baden gegangen mit meinen
hochfahrenden plänen nach einem solchen
erlebnis ist mein geschäft ruhig der
griff in dem moment auch dass gerade die
die sich über einen lustig machen angst
haben selber etwas zu wagen von dem
waren pioniere den echten unternehmern
obwohl ich sehr viel zuspruch
du bist gescheitert beim nächsten mal
schaffst du erst wir unterstützen dich
bist du die super deponie sonst wäre das
abenteuer schocks wie kein unternehmer
ist angst davor hat aus der eigenen
komfortzone heraus zu treten und sich
vor dem scheitern fürchtet wird
glücklich sein über den misserfolg
man hat sie viele freunde die sich über
deinen scheitern freuen ich das verstehe
ich ja und sie haben ja dann nicht
aufgegeben sie haben tatsächlich ein
drittes mal versucht und dann geklappt
wir haben in meinem team jeden versuch
auf ganz andere art eingepackt richard
branson steve fossett verfügten über
milliarden und sie hatten riesige teams
aber nach jedem fehlversuche haben sie
denselben ballon gebaut und ihn auf
dieselbe weise gesteuert
sie hatten auf die falsche technologie
und die falsche strategie gesetzt und
die selben fehler jedes mal wiederholt
sie sind also jedes mal aus demselben
grund gescheitert im gegensatz zu mir
jeder meiner misserfolge hatte eine
andere ursache
damit konnten wir die technologie und
unsere flug strategie schritt für
schritt verbessern
beim dritten versuch hatten wir einen
großartigen balance der sehr viel
weniger gas verbraucht als die der
konkurrenten
damit konnten wir 20 tage lang fliegen
das ist genau so schaffen wir den
längsten flug in der geschichte der
aviatik und das ist auch wieder ein
interessanter punkt den man bei ihnen
lernen kann dass sie nämlich sagen die
wahre innovation die besteht nicht darin
das was wir haben immer besser zu machen
sondern wirklich einen schritt auf die
seite zu stehen oder eben die flughöhe
zu ändern und was neues zu denken
er hat zum beispiel ein sehr
eingeleuchtet dass sie gesagt haben die
glühbirne
wurde natürlich nichts von den kerzen
produzenten erfunden sondern die neue
idee für das neue licht musste von außen
kommen
darum ist es wichtig dies zu verstehen
es wurde uns beigebracht ein seriöser
und gewohnheiten festzuhalten und immer
auf derselben flughöhe und in dieselbe
richtung unterwegs zu sein
drehen dann die winde des lebens sind
wir verloren weil wir mit dem
unvorhersehbaren nicht umzugehen wissen
das sollten wir ändern
wir sollten begreifen dass das ungewisse
die fragen und zweifel mächtige
impulsgeber sind für unsere kreativität
vorstellungskraft und leistungsfähigkeit
in einer routine situation ist man nicht
leistungsfähig es fehlt eine
aufmerksamkeit
man fährt auf autopilot schaltet man den
autopiloten aus ist man anfangs etwas
verloren und ratlos angesichts der
unvertrauten situation plötzlich ist man
gezwungen sich zu hinterfragen und
entdeckt dabei das vertrauen viel
wichtiger ist als muten verdoppeln
choral solakov mag helfen gelang die
angst anzukämpfen das kann funktionieren
wenn sie aber auf ihre ressourcen
vertrauen
begreifen sie dass ihnen in einer sehr
schwierigen lage ihre ganze kreativität
leistungsfähigkeit und ihr ganzes
potenzial zur verfügung stehen
sie können alles in ihrem innern abrufen
so versuchen den erfolg zu wissen wo die
discovery nun ist es sicher so dass es
ein stück weit in unserer hand liegt die
hier mit dem scheitern umgehen und zu
geben bereit sind die flughöhe zu ändern
und aus der krise etwas zu machen
trotzdem ist es auch so dass nicht alle
menschen die gleichen startbedingungen
haben und nicht alle das gleiche
ausgangsmaterial und in ihrem fall ist
es ja so dass ihr ihre startbedingungen
sozusagen insofern günstig waren dass
sie schon in eine abenteurer familie
hineingeboren worden sind und ich möchte
gerne mit ihnen ganz kurz zurückblicken
dieses objekt ein plexiglas fenster hat
bertram peters großvater op speaker
erfunden
zusammen mit seinem freund jacques
cousteau weiteres ihnen oder sehr gut
ein
die lücke ist damit wasserdicht
verschlossen naja physikern ingenieuren
er hatte viele ideen finden gemacht dass
batista ist eine sache die druckkabine
ist eine andere sache wenn er jetzt
seine hände ja das hat das vergessen ist
und wer hat praktische straße für die
welt aufgemacht
der flug geht auf 16.000 meter 1932 ein
rekord auch die tiefe fasziniert wie
speaker immer wieder zusammen mit seinem
sohn jacques piccard taucht er in
italien mit dem neuen unterseeboot
triester 1953 gelingt es ihnen vor der
insel ponza auf 3150 meter tiefe zu
tauchen
drees der wird von der amerikanischen
marine gekauft man will damit den
tiefsten punkt der weltmeere erforschen
im marianengraben bei der insel guam
gelingt taktiker zusammen mit seinem
amerikanischen begleiter der tiefen
rekord von 11.000 metern mehr als fünf
stunden sind sie unterwegs bis sie den
boden berühren
der amerikanische präsident eisenhower
ist begeistert erika für diese
außergewöhnliche tat mit einem orden
verpflichtet eine solche
familiengeschichte reserve süd-chemie
mein vater und großvater haben in mir
die lust auf die welt da draußen geweckt
die lust auf die technik die
wissenschaft oder das abenteuer die welt
aber ich hatte auch eine mutter
es war meine mutter die philosophie
psychologie und das spirituelle nahe
gebracht hat so dass ich diese seite
verzierten wollte und psychiater war die
äußere welt ist also die meines
großvaters und vaters die innere welt
die meine mutter
ich hatte also glück weil ich durch
meine familie gefördert wurde mich in
beide richtungen zu entfalten wenn
jemand nicht solche startbedingungen hat
also vielleicht nehme ich mal an eine
person die im moment in syrien geboren
wird würden sie auch dieser person sagen
mach etwas aus deinem leben du musst
eigentlich nur die flughöhe ändern
nicht alle haben das glück für diese
dinge sensibilisiert worden zu sein
vielleicht braucht es dann eine andere
sprache
aber es ist grundsätzlich genau das
gleiche
es gibt auch in den elendsvierteln von
bangladesch menschen ihr schaffen die
sich fragen stellen und etwas aus ihrem
leben machen wollen und dem
elendsviertel entkommen es bleibt ein
rätsel weshalb es einzeln gelingt und
der andere nicht
oft ist es auch eine frage wen man
trifft sind sehr wichtig sei es die
begegnung mit einem lehrer an der schule
einem nachbarn jemandem aus der familie
einem freund oder eine
zufallsbekanntschaft es braucht eine
offenheit für begegnungen die einen
herausfordern und alter
aktiven aufzeigen manchmal gelingt ein
leben dank solcher rollenbildern die
einem etwas vor lieber einem fußballer
oder schauspieler
bei mir waren als die astronauten die
flugpioniere so etwas anzustreben ist
allen möglich natürlich gibt es äußerst
schwierige umstände
wer nichts zu essen und zu trinken hat
kann sich nicht um philosophische fragen
kann
aber hier kommt vielleicht die
verantwortung derer zum zug in ihrem
leben glück gehabt haben man muss
anderen helfen
man muss ihnen helfen sich auszudrücken
eine solche hilfe beschränkt sich nicht
auf geldleistungen hilfe bedeutet
mitleid zu fühlen
respektvoll zu sein mit rat zur seite zu
stehen
deshalb gebe ich auch interviews in
afrikanischen ländern
meine stiftung uns auf haupt kümmert
sich um kinder mit einer seltenen und
unbeachteten krankheit noma eine
schreckliche krankheit die aus dem elend
entsteht unter ernährte kinder deren
mutter bereits während der
schwangerschaft nicht genug zu essen
hatte leiden oft an einer immunschwäche
wodurch die bakterien im mundraum nicht
mehr in schach gehalten werden kann
in der folge zersetzt sich das gesichts
gewebe die kinder haben dann riesige
löcher im gesicht das ist schrecklich
wer also das glück gehabt hat sich im
leben entfalten zu können steht in der
pflicht anderen zu helfen sich zu
entfalten und etwas für sie zu tun also
beide dinge sind wichtig für sie
einerseits eben von ihrem von ihren
glücklichen startbedingungen aus
einerseits ihre abenteuer anzufangen
aber anders als auch die anderen
teilhaben zu lassen zu helfen
eine weisheit die sie auch immer wieder
predigen oder verteidigen ist eigentlich
ein historische weiß hat nämlich zu
unterscheiden zwischen dem was wir eben
ende
dann können und dem was ihren nicht
ändern können wie viel da auch das gebet
ein von reinhold niebuhr großen
theologen das auch bei den anonymen
alkoholikern eine große rolle spielt
nämlich diese idee gott soll mehr
gelassenheit geben das hinzunehmen was
ich nicht ändern kann den mut das zu
ändern was ich ändern kann und und das
ist glaube ich die pflanze die weisheit
das eine vom anderen zu unterscheiden
herr picard das interessiert mich wie
lernen wir zu unterscheiden was sich
ändern lässt und was ihr annehmen müssen
die frage ob man gegen etwas an kämpfen
soll stellt sich immer wieder handle ich
wie ein flug akrobatik not der gegen die
winde kämpft weil hier etwas verändern
kann oder verhalte ich mich wie der
heißluftballon claude der mit dem wind
geht ihnen nicht ändern kann
oder seine flughöhe ändern wir haben
sehr häufig das falsche gelernt wenn man
auf etwas unabänderliches trifft das
bedeutet stress oder dinge die man sehr
wohl ändern könnte einfach hinzunehmen
dass ist fatalismus dies zu lernen wäre
also sehr wichtig die weisheit besteht
tatsächlich darin das eine vom anderen
unterscheiden zu können und zu wissen
worauf man seine energie im eigenen
leben lenken soll
damit es nützlich und nicht verschwendet
ist
ich würde gern noch mehr herausfinden
wie sie diese weisheit den ticket haben
weil wenn ich ihr leben und gucke dann
denke ich ja lange zeit eben wirklich
wie auf zwei hochzeiten getanzt nämlich
einerseits medizinstudium psychiater
diese ganzen hypnose kurse die sich
angeeignet haben dieses wissen und
andererseits eben die arten des fliegens
immer wieder neue arten also delta
flieger dann ballon dann das
solarflugzeug sie haben jetzt auch
erklärt dass das aus ihrer familie kommt
beide stränge
aber wie haben sie entschieden
irgendwann zu sagen ich mache jetzt
nicht mehr die große karriere als sich
japan sondern ich setze jetzt auf das
frieden dass du weil ich ein häretiker
bin
in der harry sie akzeptiert man kein
offizielles dogma ich war bereits im
medizinstudium ein häretiker ich habe
kurse in akupunktur ayurveda und
traditioneller chinesischer medizin
gelegt weil wir das wissen von der
universität nicht gereicht hat
die fragen die ich mir war das leben
stellte wurden dort nicht beantwortet
eines tages ich arbeitete als
medizinstudent in der notfallaufnahme
wurde eine frau nach einem selbstmord
versucht hat aufgenommen sie erkannte
keinen sinn im leben in der psychiatrie
vorlesung am nächsten tag habe ich die
hand und fragte vor 400 studenten was
tun wir wenn wir einen patienten
gegenüber stehen der sich umbringen will
weil er keinen sinn im leben sieht der
professor antwortete hier bekommen sie
den mittel an die hand und sich ja dazu
werden für fragen des glaubens sollen
die patienten in die kirche
ich fand das komplett falsche koppelt
man kann die spirituelle welt nicht von
der therapeutischen oder der alltagswelt
abtrennen
die patienten kommen zu uns mit ihrem
leben ihren ängsten ihren hoffnungen
ihren leiden und es ist an uns
therapeuten uns ihnen anzupassen deshalb
habe ich anderswo nach antworten gesucht
in der hypnose habe ich die beste
entsprechung gefunden
wir haben 20 jahre lang patienten mit
hus behandelt
und es hat sehr gut funktioniert
patienten lernen dabei ihre eigenen
ressourcen zu nutzen
unsere patienten haben sich oft in ihr
symptom zurückgezogen mit der hypnose
schafft man es sie aus ihrem problem
heraus zu führen und ihnen ihr leben
zurück zu gehen
das symptom macht sie nicht mehr aus
sondern es wird zu einem kleinen teil
damit erhalten die patienten die chance
sich zu öffnen sich selbst neu zu
erfahren es erschließen sich nicht nur
neue möglichkeiten in der berufswelt und
der familie sondern auch eine
spirituelle welt als entdecker und damit
komme ich zu ihrer frage bin ich nicht
zufrieden mit dem was ich sehe keine
antwort ist abschließend nichts was man
mir zeigt gehört mir
ich bin wissens begehrlich und stets
gewillt sämtliche elemente neu zu ordnen
auch in der religion ich bin christlich
erzogen worden aber das christentum
reicht mir nicht mit seinem üblichen
erklärungen von gott im leben und dem
tod
ich beschäftige mich auch mit
autistischen buddhistischer und
journalistischen erklärungen und den
großen häretiker der geschichte denn sie
bilden für mich die puzzleteile die
zusammengesetzt einen größeren sinn
ergeben als den der aus einer engen
dogmatischen sichtweise und wenn man
nicht dogmatisch denkt dann ist man eben
auch in der lage aus der krise etwas zu
machen was sie ein abenteuer nennen und
für mich war das nicht so ein
schlüsselsatz bei ihnen dass sie sagen
eine krise die man annimmt ist ein
abenteuer eine krise die man ablehnt
bleibt der krise würden sie so weit
gehen und sagen das gilt auch jetzt für
diese corona krise müssen wir das
einfach annehmen und dann wird sein
großes abenteuer und bedenkt die heutige
corona krise ist ein abenteuer das wir
uns aus unserer gewohnten welt heraus
befördert und vereine außergewöhnliche
situation stellt extra-loch wir haben
die wahl das alles schrecklich zu finden
und abzunehmen
dann leiden wir uns in deprimiert und
die schreckliche krise bewahrheitet sich
oder die sagen uns die welt war vorher
instabil zerbrechlich ungerecht
verschmutzt und gefährlich was für eine
welt wollen wir heute warum opel fabrik
damit wird aus dieser krise etwas
außerordentliches ein schöpferisches
abenteuer
man könnte die wirtschaftliche und
finanzielle hilfe für die unternehmen
unter gewissen auflagen vergeben und so
sicherstellen dass der wiederaufbau der
wirtschaft nachhaltig wird sauberer
effizienter umweltfreundlicher eine welt
in der alles läuft ist schwierig zu
verändern
heute funktioniert nichts mehr das gibt
uns die außerordentliche chance eine
welt aufzubauen die besser sein wird als
die welt vorher nicht so groß trier geld
gemacht schreibt die flughöhe zu ändern
bedeutet also die krise zu nutzen um
gestärkt aus ihr hervorzugehen und nicht
auf tiefere stufe oder auf der gleichen
flughöhe vorher aber das problem ist
doch wir sind nicht alleine in dieser
krise es gibt ganz viele andere menschen
die sind nämlich eine gesellschaft in
dieser krise und ist es manchmal nicht
frustrierend für sie sie möchten gerne
jede krise aus abenteuer sehen und die
sache verändern aber ganz viele menschen
wollen das nicht möchten gerne dass die
sache weitergeht wie bisher nehmen und
servierte die jungtiere sich durch nun
es gibt immer leute die sich gegen den
wandel stellen und sämtliche chancen die
ihnen das leben bietet verpassen
sie haben ein schlechtes leben und
fragen nach dem warum
dann gibt es andere die sie fragen was
könnte ich aus dieser situation machen
wie könnte ich sie nutzen ihr leben
öffnet entfaltet und verbessert sich
genauso in der gesellschaft es gibt
politische parteien und unternehmen die
täglich ein intensives lobbying
betreiben um zur welt von früher
zurückzukehren
fossile brennstoffe als primäre
energiequelle weiter behalten
verschmutzen der autos auf die straße
zurück zu bringen den menschen schlecht
isolierte häuser mit veralteten
heizungen bereitzustellen
diese welt von früher ist eine
katastrophe ich mache genau das
umgekehrte in der stiftungshalle impuls
habe ich zwölf unternehmensführer großer
konzerne
wenn ein tisch gebracht gemeinsam haben
wir einen artikel verfasst den
verschiedenen medien publiziert wurde
wir verlangen darin eine andere welt und
sehr viel ehrgeizigere klimaziele und
strikte umweltregeln seitens der politik
damit die krise zu etwas nütze ist und
die welt die wir heute vorbereiten
gerechten nachhaltiger und
umweltfreundlicher sein wird mitgemacht
haben unter anderem der ceo von nestlé
keine kleine firma der eigentümer von
meier dennis louis vitton die bank pnb
paribas und air france sie alle haben
sich verpflichtet ihren beitrag für eine
umweltfreundlichere welt nach der krise
zu leisten
anders als vor zehn jahren gibt es heute
die lösungen dafür dass sich das auch
finanziell rechnet muss man sie nutzen
sophie moser morocha der gruppe liegen
diese das ist ja auch eine ihrer
wichtigen botschaften mit solar impuls
dass sie gesagt haben das wollen sie
zeigen es geht nicht mehr darum auf
abenteurer den mond zu erobern oder noch
schneller zu fliegen oder ein land zu
entdecken was noch niemand gesehen hat
sondern es geht jetzt darum die welt zu
retten und sie eben nachhaltig zu
gestalten auch für die zukünftigen
generationen
und wenn wir über diese botschaft
sprechen dann ist es ja eben wirklich
auch wichtig noch einmal zu überlegen
wie kommt man eigentlich an stil und sie
haben jetzt mehrere male schon erwähnt
alleine abenteurer zu sein ist das ein
aber man braucht auch andere menschen
man braucht ein team man braucht freunde
aber nicht immer sind die sachen so
einfach es gibt natürlich auch
rivalitäten und sie haben ein anderes
buch geschrieben zusammen mit andré
borschberg zusammen
und mich hat die offenheit in diesem
buch sehr beeindruckt sie zeigen nämlich
in diesem buch was passiert wenn zwei
abenteuerlustige enorm intelligente
charmante persönlichkeiten die aber
natürlich auch gerne im rampenlicht
stehen zusammen arbeiten und es zu
rivalitäten kommt das war ja auch nicht
immer einfach
und es gab auch immer mal wieder ganz
brenzlige situationen im team es gab
auch konflikte ein moment in dem die
situation im team besonders kritisch
wurde war bei einem flug von japan nach
hawaii bei dem andré borschberg das
flugzeug
die uns bei der überquerung eines meeres
wird im pazifik gibt es eben einen punkt
ab dem ein umkehren nicht mehr möglich
ist kurz davor zeigten tests dass das
system nicht funktioniert wird aus den
schlafenden piloten wenn es ein problem
gibt mit dem autopiloten alle ingenieure
wollten in dem moment umkehren solange
es noch möglich ist sie und andere
baustelle wollten hingegen weiter
fliegen
schauen wir uns diesen brenzligen moment
ganz kurz an aus meiner sicht als
ingenieur ist die lage klar wir sollten
umkehren und die probleme beheben
ich möchte eines klarstellen wir können
die hier unten am boden nur beschränkt
helfen wenn du dich dazu entschließt
weiterzumachen bist du da oben ganz auf
sich alleine gestellt
das musst du bei deiner entscheidung
berücksichtigt für andré und mich war
das überhaupt kein grund den flug
abzubrechen
für einige ingenieure hingegen schon
weil das flugzeug nicht zu 100%
betriebsfähig war und nicht alle systeme
funktionierten
innerhalb des teams wurde daher
verhandelt zwischen jenen die nach japan
zurückkehren wollten und andré und mir
und es war klar dass wir zurück in japan
wegen der regenzeit und so weiter nicht
erneut starten würden
das war ein psychodrama wir haben so
viele jahre an diesem flugzeug
gearbeitet versucht das beste zu tun
und dann war ich am telefon und die
beiden manager haben gedrückt gedrückt
und gesagt wir entscheiden letztlich
also ihr seid nur beratend und das habe
ich schon zum teil einfach als schwierig
oder als affront empfunden
ich kann nicht verstehen dass andere
anwärter als manager sich gegen das
ganze team stellen können
sie zwingen uns etwas zu unterstützen
dass niemand machen möchte
das ist für mich eine große enttäuschung
das muss ich wirklich sagen wir hören
dir zu peter erinnert euch an diesen
satz was immer in der zukunft passieren
mögen ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger
satz den ich soeben gesagt habe wenn du
den philosophen spiels peter dann spiele
ich den ingenieur vertraue ich glaube
wir müssen dieses gespräch nun beenden
ich hänge auf soll so viele leute die
die arbeit gemacht haben um zwei als
user entscheiden nachher wir machen so
oder so und es kann dazu führen dass man
einfach den flieger zerstört das habe
ich das war emotional schwierig für mich
auch wenn die piloten das sagen sie
übernehmen das risiko aber auch mein
eigenes leben ist anders wenn der pilot
stirbt ich werde das für den rest von
meinem leben mittragen
herr picard das problem nicht lösen
wurde weiter geflogen und es ist alles
gut gegangen
was wäre gewesen wenn es zum unfall
gekommen wäre
unter der situation und der situation
flog das flugzeug gut und das wetter war
endlich günstig für den flug von japan
nach hawaii ein kleines detail aber ließ
die ingenieure in panik ausbrechen
man muss etwas begreifen
in einem solchen projekt hatten die
ingenieure die aufgabe ein flugzeug zu
bauen
sie waren nicht dafür da in ein
abenteuer das zepter zu übernehmen
das abenteuer lag in der hand von andré
borschberg und mir in einem bestimmten
moment kommt es zur stabübergabe von
denen die das flugzeug gebaut haben zu
denen die es fliegt ja ungeniert liebten
ihr flugzeug und ich denke sie liebten
auch andré und mich sie wollten auf
keinen fall dass uns etwas zustößt
eine rückkehr nach japan hätte das
projekt beerdigt wir stand nach anfang
der taifun saison japaner hätten eine
administrative untersuchung zum grund
unserer rückkehr durchgeführt das
flugzeug hätte sie nie mehr abgehoben
mein ziel war das gelingen des projekts
und reber einverstanden weiterzumachen
der baum steuer wir sind beide zu
derselben entscheidung gekommen
in einer solchen situation muss man den
sprung ins ungewisse wagen wir hatten ja
nicht die absicht eine neue
fluggesellschaft zu gründen wo man eine
verantwortung hat für 200 passagiere
es war ein abenteuer in der
experimentellen charakter
wir wollten zeigen was mit erneuerbaren
energien möglich ist
waren beide bereits die entsprechenden
risiken einzugehen
ein fallschirm und ein rettungsboot
hätten uns im schlimmsten fall eine
überlebens chance geboten
das hatten wir in kauf genommen und wenn
jetzt ihr freund und kollege andré
borschberg in dem moment gesagt hätte
ich mache mich weiter ich drehe um
hätten sie das auch unterstützt
er war am steuer und hatte folglich das
letzte wort er hätte sich für eine
rückkehr nach japan entscheiden können
aber ich habe mich ja nicht mit einem
beamten zu
angetan sondern mit jemandem der aus dem
selben holz geschnitzt ist für ihn wie
für mich stand das weiter machen außer
frage
ende der woche sehr hoch ist unsere welt
strebt zum null risiko
die komplette vermeidung von risiken ist
aber gefährlich der auseinandersetzung
mit risiken lehrt uns wachsam
konzentrierter und leistungsfähiger zu
sein
das bringt uns weiter das größte wagnis
ihr leben besteht darin wie ein risiko
einzugehen
in diesem zusammenhang mit andre
borschberg da waren sie ja zu zweit aber
sie haben sich abgewechselt wie sie
schon gesagt haben einmal sind sie
gefroren einmal ist er geflogen
im ballon breitling orbiter waren sie zu
zweit in diesem korb was war einfacher
zu zweit da oben in den lüften oder
alleine
das schwierigste war sind zu zweit einen
sitz und kommt zu teilen
das hat mit dem ballon im ballon war es
einfach dort gab es zwei plätze und ich
konnte den kopiloten auswählen
ich will große stücke auf brian jones
und wir verstanden uns auch sehr gut
allerdings mussten wir zuerst lernen
miteinander zu kommunizieren
vielleicht kommen wir ja noch darauf
zurück bei solar impuls wussten wir uns
die fliege aufteilen und er war der
bessere pilot ich verfügte über meine
erfahrung als entdecker die er nicht
hatte er hatte ja noch nie einen
20-tägigen flug im heißluftballon
gemacht das aufteilen der flüge acht die
konflikte mit sich denn es gab bestimmte
flüge die wir beide unbedingt wollten
mit diesem buch wollte nicht zeigen was
hinter einem solchen unterfangen
das muss ein und satz vorlesen war das
ist so schön sie schreiben in diesem
buch es hat mich wirklich berührt sie
mussten lernen zu teilen die flüge die
bekanntheit die entscheidungen
das ist sehr ehrlich wir haben in diesem
buch alles aufgeregt wir wollten einen
blick hinter die kulissen des abenteuers
erlaube die attraktiven medien bilder
des flugzeugs über den schönsten
gegenden sind das eine aber was steckt
hinter all dem ein problem harry
konflikten und rivalitäten und an
freundschaft lustigerweise hat mir auch
einer meiner patienten gesagt dass er
das buch in der paartherapie nutzt um zu
lernen mit seiner frau zu kommunizieren
die gerne zum schluss auf etwas
zurückkommen was sie bereits angetönt
haben nämlich ihre spiritualität die
ihnen sehr wichtig ist dass sie immer
noch an diesem objekt das sie
mitgebracht hat man diesen glücksbringer
aber auch an dem was sie schreiben man
merkt immer wieder für sie ist diese
welt nicht einfach ein sinnloser
teilchen haufen sondern es gibt mehr
es gibt mehr in dieser welt sie
schreiben in ihrem buch auch dass sie
glauben dass krisen eigentlich
sprungbretter sind um zu mehr
spiritualität zu mehr spiritueller
erkenntnis zu gelangen
glauben sie dass das einer der gründe
ist warum so viele menschen auch freude
haben an extremsport über den
extremsport können wir uns mit etwas
wesentliches in uns verbinden und aus
der routine und der sicherheit aus
brechen wir uns beruhigen aber nicht
helfen uns weiter zu entwickeln
nur am morgen hatte ich habe mich immer
dafür interessiert was uns lebenskrisen
bringen können in meiner medizinischen
doktorarbeit zur pädagogik der
schicksals
fragte ich frauen und männer die
schreckliches erlebt haben ob sie durch
diese dramen gestärkt oder gebrochen
wurden wie hoch sie dran
erstaunlicherweise haben fast alle
erklärt sie seien durch ihre
schicksalsschläge stärker geworden ihre
beziehung zu sich und zu anderen während
tiefer und auch spirituelle während sie
das leben vorher als selbstverständlich
ansehen und sich kaum fragen stellten
suchten sie nachher einen sinn in ihrem
leben
wichtiger als alle ballons flugzeuge
krisen und abenteuer ist die frage was
man mit seinem leben anfangen will
in welchen sinn macht wer denkt dass er
aus dem nirgendwo kommt und ins
nirgendwo geht es um das ziel des lebens
darin besteht reichen glücklich zu sein
den wird die kleinste krise umbringen
wenn man aber versteht dass man von
irgendwoher kommt ohne zu wissen woher
und dass man irgendwo hingehen ohne zu
wissen wohin und das der sinn des lebens
darin besteht sich weiterzuentwickeln
und sich über mehr weisheit güte
mitgefühl und positive lebensenergie
einzubringen
dann öffnet sich einen sinn hinter allen
religiösen strömungen und philosophien
deren aussagen sich ja kaum voneinander
unterscheiden
fast alles sagen sie wir sollen unser
bewusstsein
unser mitgefühl unserer weisheit und
lebensenergie erweitern um uns
weiterzuentwickeln damit wir uns in
einer welt mit weniger dualität
konflikten und leiden wiederfinden
interessant ist der buddhistische weg
dem leiden das zum leben gehört nicht an
zu hoffen
ich hatte immer den eindruck es gibt
eigentlich zwei arten in diesem leben zu
stehen es gibt entweder diese idee
gläubig zu sein zu denken es gibt einen
grund warum ich hier bin es gibt einen
grund warum ich diesen weg gehen und
wohin ich gehe
und ich bin gehalten von einer
höheren macht dann habe ich das problem
dass ich mich fragen muss warum
nächtliche höhere macht zu das so
grausame dinge passieren
oder ich glaube nicht an diese höhere
macht stehe allein in dieser welt musst
dich absurdität aushalten der ich keinen
sinn geben kann
dann habe ich das problem das ich nicht
gehalten bringen
beide arten im leben zu stehen haben ein
problem im grunde genommen
unsere welt ist eine schöpfung und in
jeder schöpfung gibt es eine dualität es
gibt nicht die eine seite ohne die
andere
es gibt tage nacht gut schwarz und weiß
links und rechts leiden und glück alles
ist dualität weil die welt in der
materie existiert wie dieser in dem
milieu seit zehntausenden jahren sagen
unseren propheten dezidierte weise und
heilsbringer dass das ziel darin besteht
aus dieser inkarnation in der materie
aus dem ries sich geistig zu erheben und
in ein universum zurückzukehren in dem
es keine dualität geht in ein universum
der einzig kite in allen
monotheistischen religionen wird gott
als eine krafteinheit dargestellt in der
es kein gut und böse gibt das ziel
besteht darin über spirituelle wege aus
der materialistischen welt auszubrechen
die uns leiten lässt
dort wo ist sie jedoch sortierte
realistin versuche ich sehe schon wenn
man mit einem abenteurer spricht dann
geht es auch ein abenteuer reiches
gespräch wir haben eine große fahrt
unternommen durch die großen fragen die
uns wahrscheinlich alle letztlich
beschäftigen
ich danke ihnen ganz ganz herzlich egal
dass sie hierher gekommen sind zu uns
ins studio danke sehr
die boku danke ja nächste woche machen
die eine gesprächspause und zeigen einen
film über einen der von sich sagt ich
bin dynamik zumindest hat friedrich
nietzsche interview
manches auf den kopf gestellt aber war
auch der für den inhalten der kinder zu
am kommenden sonntag
und jetzt gleich begleiten wir die
rapperin m
die mit ihrem sound die welt erobert hat
die rolle eines popstars jedoch immer
wieder sprengt danke fürs interesse
bleiben sie zuversichtlich gebaut
[Musik]